Nick Fury is a linchpin of the MCU not
only did the character manage to bring
together the Avengers but he also
discovered Captain Marvel took down
Hydra and has saved the world of
numerous times but what if the praise we
give Him isn't warranted what if it was
never Nick Fury doing all of those
amazing things well as a pretty big fan
theory mounting at the moment that Nick
Fury may not be exactly what we think so
I thought I'd put together the evidence
that supports this and why it's so
important this is full spoilers ahead so
if you haven't seen Captain Marvel yet
and don't want anything from the rest of
the MCU spoiled and I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I explain it so you don't
have to ok so firstly Marvel have been
pretty good at foreshadowing things and
slotting fan theories into their movies
both Wakanda and Peter Parker make
appearances in Iron Man 2 and even
Stanley was confirmed as a watcher
informant in guardians of the galaxy vol
2 there's also of course Thanos who made
an appearance at the end of the Avengers
bar before he was ever intended to be
brought into the universe it's clear
that they're pretty smart when it comes
to setting things up and there's a big
thing of note that gets mentioned in
Captain Marvel that when we look back
over the MCU films appears to have some
significance okay so when Captain Marvel
in Nick Fury meet in a bar at about the
midpoint of the movie they test each
other to see if they can prove that they
are not scrolls as a way to prove that
he's definitely human Fury tells
something so secret about himself that a
scroll would never know it and that is
they can't eat toast that has been cut
diagonally it's a pretty weird remark
that seems so random that it's stranger
was even included but if we look at age
of Ultron there's a pretty clear reason
why this may have been put into the
movie this is because in the farm scene
from that film when Fury reunites with
the team once more he slices up a
sandwich into triangles before eating it
okay okay so I know this isn't toast but
you would still think that the rules
would apply it's the only time we ever
see fury eat and those well versed in
film studies and know that food in films
is often chosen for very deliberate
reasons whilst this may be a bit of a
stretch there's actually a lot to back
it up
firstly when the Scrolls land on earth
in Captain Marvel it's clearly fought in
the group yet only three are accounted
for in the film that means that one of
them disappeared and was never seen or
heard from again
and therefore remained on earth in
addition to this there's leaked concept
art of fury transforming into a scroll
in the Captain Marvel movie book Captain
Marvel the R of the movie so whilst it
may not have made it to the film it's
clear that the creators at least
considered that the character could be
one although a lot of fans are saying
that Fury was swapped out at the end of
Captain Marvel as he says his eye is
fine and there ends up wearing a patch I
actually think it happened at a later
date one thing that always bugged me
about the Winter Soldier is that we see
fury die in a public hospital where he
wouldn't really have the opportunity to
fake his own death he later pops up in
the film stating that it was all an act
but this has just always kind of got to
me and in my opinion it seemed like lazy
writing however if the theory is true
then this creates the perfect
opportunity for the scroll to step in in
the absence of fury the scroll could
step forward assume his place and begin
returning the favor for the man who
saved his people this also explains why
I would have knowledge of Captain Marvel
and the inner workings of shield as he
could have infiltrated them early on
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this theory and if you agree with me
the toast thing with me is a pretty big
red flag that I can't really talk up to
anything else and it definitely seems
like it was included in the script to
reference the one time that we saw fury
eat obviously there's gonna be loads of
people that agree loads of people that
disagree and loads of people that just
have even better theories make sure you
leave them in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of the full timeline of the
tesseract which will be linked at the
end of this video this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like
it's
scribe thanks again for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]